[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Why
don't we get started.
We're going to start
by finishing up
our lecture on costs,
with a concept I
didn't get to cover last time.
Then we'll move on to
talking about competition.
So I want to start by talking
about one concept on costs
we didn't get the
cover last time,
which is fixed
versus sunk costs.
And sunk costs are an
important term in economics,
so I want to make sure people
understand what they are.
Sunk costs are essentially
costs that cannot be changed,
no matter what action you
take from this date forward.
So in some sense, some costs
are long-run fixed costs.
I know we said in the
long run, nothing's fixed.
But a sunk cost is the idea of
an investment that once made,
can never, ever be changed.
So the thing is, if we think
about it in the short run,
let's imagine you're a doctor.
In the short run,
your variable costs
are how many hours you work,
or the nurses you employ,
or the physician
assistants you employ.
In the long run,
your fixed costs
or how big your office is.
You can get a bigger
office or smaller office.
But your sunk cost is
having gone to med school.
You can ever undo having
gone to med school.
Having paid that
cost, it is sunk.
It is gone.
You're never going to--
you could go to more med school.
You could take
supplementary classes,
but you can never undo
having gone to med school.
So that's the sense in which
some things are sunk costs.
They're investments that
are made that can never,
essentially, be undone.
And essentially, we can think of
these as long-run fixed costs,
which I know is really
confusing, because the long run
is when costs aren't fixed.
But that's essentially
what they amount to.
Now, sunk costs turn out to
have a very important place
in economic lore, because
the thing about sunk costs
is it's hard to
think about them.
It's hard to remember the rule
that sunk costs are always
sunk.
So let me give you one example--
it's in one of my videos
for the 1401X videos that
supplement this course.
But if you've seen
it, I apologize.
We'll go through it again,
which is literally a case where
I got this wrong two years ago.
So about two and
a half years ago,
I made the decision
that I take my wife
to go see the band Journey.
So I went and I bought
tickets, and the tickets
were $240 for the pair--
pretty good tickets at a big
stadium, $240 for the pair.
Then about a month
before the show,
I was looking, and
realized I didn't actually
like Journey that much.
I like-- I love a
couple of their songs.
I looked at the set list.
I'm like, I don't really like
that many of their songs.
There's a couple I love, but
I don't want to sit there.
It's a couple
hours to get there.
I don't want to
sit there all night
for two songs that I like.
I want to sell them.
So you can sell
tickets through StubHub
or other secondary
mechanisms, but you
have to decide what price
you're going to ask.
And I said, I gotta at
least make back my $240.
That's my goal.
And then I realized
I was thinking
about it completely wrong.
I didn't realize immediately,
but I was [INAUDIBLE] about it
completely wrong--
that the $240 was already gone.
The fact I spent $240, given
that I'd already spent it,
is irrelevant.
How should I think about it?
I should only ask
how much am I still
willing to pay to see Journey?
And as long as someone else is
willing to pay more than that,
I should sell them my tickets.
And if they're not, I should go.
So let's say, for
example, I decided,
I'd still pay $100 for my
wife and I to go see Journey.
Then I should say, as long as
the tickets sell for more than
$100, I'll sell them, but if
it's less than $100, I won't.
And the fact I paid
$240 is irrelevant--
that's gone.
That is a sunk cost.
So a common [INAUDIBLE]
is the sunk cost fallacy--
the notion we pay
attention to things
that don't matter anymore.
Having spent that
money was irrelevant.
All that mattered was the
decision looking forward,
which was, do I want to go or
do I want to sell the tickets?
And that decision simply
depends on how much
I was willing to pay now.
Now that's confusing.
I've explained this.
If you guys get it,
you're a rare breed.
I've tried this story on many
people, and they're, like, no,
of course it matters
how much you paid.
It doesn't.
AUDIENCE: Does this
kind of [INAUDIBLE]
apply to the housing
market crash,
and homeowners are trying to
sell their houses for way more
than they're worth, because
they're trying to get
some of their money back?
JONATHAN GRUBER: The sunk
cost fallacy finds its name
very much in the housing market.
Many homeowners
set as a benchmark
what they paid for their house.
They'll say, I don't want to
sell less than what I paid.
That's silly.
Doesn't matter what you paid.
What matters is how much you can
sell it for and whether or not
you want to sell at that price.
And what you paid is irrelevant.
Now, it might matter because
there are borrowing constraints
we'll get into.
You might have a mortgage
you have to pay back,
and you can't afford
to pay it back
unless you sell for
a certain price.
But aside from
that, let's imagine
you just bought
your house outright
without a mortgage
for $1 million.
Then that's irrelevant.
Whether you sell your
house for $900,000
just depends on whether
it's worth $900,000 for you
to stay there or not.
The million you
paid is irrelevant,
except if you have a mortgage
and you've borrowed it.
That can make it complicated.
So basically, sunk
costs are sunk.
Now, I ended up selling the
tickets for $220, so I did OK.
But if I thought
about it incorrectly,
I would've said that's a bummer.
I lost $20.
And in the big picture,
it is a bummer.
I never should have bought
them in the first place.
But having made that
decision to buy them,
the fact I was only willing to
pay about $100 at that point
to go and sold for $220
meant I did well, not badly.
Questions about that?
It's a confusing example.
None of your friends
understand this.
You could totally mess
with your friends' minds
by explaining this to them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] more
I might make [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: What I
mean is, think of them--
I have a set of Journey tickets.
I have a choice--
I can sell them or go.
So the only question
is, how much is it
worth to me to go to Journey?
I decided it was worth
$100 to go to Journey.
So I simply put them
on StubHub, and said
if they sell for more
than $100, I won't go.
If they sell for less
than $100, I'll go.
The fact that I paid
$240 is irrelevant.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, basically
you've lost [INAUDIBLE]..
You've lost overall you've--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN GRUBER: I lost $20.
AUDIENCE: --by making the
mistake of buying them.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, ex
ante, there was a mistake made.
But having made the
mistake, that's irrelevant.
So that's an important concept
to keep in mind, is sunk cost.
Let's go on now and move
on to the next topic, which
is the focus of the
next two lectures,
which is perfect competition.
Perfect competition.
Now, stepping back,
as we highlighted,
a lot of what we did
for producer theory
is the same as what we
did for consumer theory.
We have isoquants and isocosts
instead of indifference curves
and budget constraints,
but the same damn exercise,
same math, same graphics.
The difference was we have
a series of tangencies
between the isocosts
and isoquants,
and we didn't know which one
was the right one to choose.
With consumer theory, we
pin that down by the fact
our parents gave us a
certain amount of money.
For producer theory, there
was nothing pinning down q.
There's nothing pinning
down our total costs
we can afford to spend.
What pins that down is
an additional constraint
we bring into the system,
which is the market.
So now, we're going to take that
next step of actually deciding
what a firm produces.
What a firm produces partly
comes from all the math
we do before developing
the cost curve.
But it also comes from the fact
that firm exists in a market.
And we focused on the cost side.
Now, we turn to
the revenue side.
The markets can determine
what the firm can
make from selling that
good, and that's and that's
going to pin down how
much they produce.
Now, we're getting set of three
different market settings.
Today, we'll talk about
perfect competition, which
is the market with many,
many firms competing
to sell a homogeneous good.
I'll talk about it
more precisely later.
Then, we're going to talk--
that's one extreme.
That's the extreme of
markets that economists sort
of dream about is a
perfectly competitive market.
The other extreme
is monopoly, where
there's one firm, only one
firm that sells the good.
And then in between, we
have my favorite word
in economics-- oligopoly,
which is when there's
several firms competing to sell
a good, not as many as perfect
competition, but more than one.
That turns out to be
super complicated.
So what we do is we start
with the two extremes,
develop a set of
intuitions and rules,
and then we sort of hand-wave
a bit around oligopoly.
And that's where I
introduce the notion
of game theory, which
we'll talk about some
in a couple of lectures.
So today, we're going
to start with one
extreme-- perfect competition.
What is perfect competition?
Basically, the
technical definition
of a perfectly
competitive market
is where producers
are price takers.
A perfectly
competitive market is
one where a producer
doesn't have
any influence over the price
that they sell their good at.
They are price takers.
So I can't actually,
as one-producer market,
can't actually affect
the market price.
The market price is given to me.
When will this be true?
This will be true when the
demand for a firm's output
is perfectly elastic, when
the demand for a given firm's
output-- little q, not
the market elasticity,
but the firm elasticity--
when you have
an infinitely elastic little q.
So let's think about that case.
Let's turn to the first figure.
So we have little q2 and--
so we basically have little q,
because it's the firm's output
on the x-axis.
The y-axis is the market price.
The firm faces a perfectly
elastic demand curve.
That means that they can't
change the market price that's
charged.
So what does that mean?
That means that no matter
what their cost function
is, whether their supply
curve 1 or supply curve 2,
they always sell at price p.
So shifts in the cost function--
that is shifts in the supply
curve--
only affect how much you
sell, not the price you get.
That would be true in a
perfectly competitive market.
So what conditions make a
perfectly competitive market?
There's basically
three conditions.
The first is identical products.
A market will only be
perfectly competitive
if all the firms are selling at
least what consumers perceive
to be identical products.
They don't have to be
technologically identical.
But from a consumer's
perspective,
they have to be
viewed as identical.
The second condition is there's
full information about prices.
That is, consumers know
what every firm is charging.
So I go to market, and I know
I have full information.
And the third condition is that
there's low transaction costs,
or what you might
call "search costs,"
that it's very costless for me
to search across opportunities.
It's very costly
for me to care--
everybody's price
is perfectly posted,
and it's very costless for
me to search across them.
Sort of two and three
are kind of related.
So this is obviously
never true, much
like many of our
assumptions are never true.
But it's a useful benchmark for
thinking about a lot of what
we're going to think about.
So you want to think
about markets like this--
so for example, the classic
case you might think of is eBay.
If you go on eBay
and you search--
I just bought a pair of
72-inch red shoelaces.
There's 72-inch red
shoelace or [INAUDIBLE]
It turns out not quite--
some are flat, some are oval.
But within oval
72-inch red shoelaces,
there's literally no variation.
They're 72-inch, red shoelaces.
Now, they could be
of different quality,
and that might be unobservable.
That's why it's not perfect, but
it's pretty close to identical.
I go on eBay, and all the
prices are listed there.
So I have full
information on my prices,
and they're easy to compare.
Now, it's not perfect
because, a, there
could be unobserved
quality differences.
Some shoelaces may be made
by cheaper manufacturers.
Others are easier
to break or fray.
And the second reason is that I
might not have full information
about prices, because at
least in the old days--
eBay's changed this--
they can price compare on
the non-shipping cost price.
Now eBay's fixed this.
You get the price
including shipping costs.
So in the old days,
you could shop,
and think you had
the cheapest deal,
but it turned out when you
add shipping costs, it wasn't.
So even eBay, which is sort of
the economist's dream platform,
doesn't quite meet
these conditions,
but it's about as
close as you can come.
Now, the other example
I like to point to
is like buying little
knickknacks in a tourist area.
That basically, if you've
ever gone to a tourist area
and tried to buy a little
knickknack like a replica
of the Eiffel Tower
around the Eiffel Tower,
there's a bunch of guys with
blankets, out selling them.
And it's pretty easy to get see
they're all the same replicas.
And it's pretty easy
to ask the guy, what
do you want for your
Eiffel tower replica?
So that's another market.
Now, I taught this
as a casual example.
Someone watched this video from
when I did this four years ago,
and went to the Eiffel Tower--
some guy in France--
and actually did the exercise
of marching from blanket
to blanket.
And he found that when you got
further from the Eiffel Tower,
they're more expensive,
because there weren't
many people selling them.
But once you got close to the
Eiffel Tower, all these guys
selling them, he
found that everyone
charged the identical price.
And he sent me a little package
of 24 little Eiffel towers.
It was really cute.
So that was sort of this
exercise in reality.
Now, the important thing
to remember, though,
is this is a perfectly
elastic, firm demand.
So I want to talk for
a second about demand
for a firm's good versus
demand for a market's good, so
firm versus market demand.
These are two different things.
And the way to think about
this, think about the concept
of residual demand.
So you could think
about the demand
for a market, demand
function for a market,
as being some Q of p.
That's a demand
function of the market.
That's this demand
curve we've been
looking at since lecture one.
It's a downward-sloping
function of the price.
And we can then think of any
given firm, little q's demand,
q of p, as equal to big Q of
p minus S0 of p, where S0 of p
we call "residual demand."
S super 0 of p is
residual demand.
It's what everyone
else is supplying.
So the demand to my firm--
once again, under
these conditions,
perfectly competitive market--
the demand to my firm is simply
the total market demand minus
what everyone else is selling.
So if I'm going to set
up my little tchotchke
blanket by the Eiffel
Tower, my demand
is going to be the total demand
for little Eiffel towers minus
what everyone else is
selling at on their blanket.
The key point is, even with
fairly inelastic, big Q,
you can get really
elastic little q.
So let's do an example.
Let's first differentiate this.
If you do dq dp,
what do you get?
You get d big Q
dp minus d S0 dp.
Now, the first term is negative,
because demand is downward
sloping.
This term is positive, dS0 dp.
The higher the price,
the more suppliers
are going to be in the market.
So it's a positive
minus a negative.
So already, we see
d little q dp is
going to be bigger in absolute
value than d big Q dp,
because dS0 dp is positive,
and you're subtracting it.
But we can actually
go further if we
assume firms are identical.
Let's assume firms
are identical,
so that little q equals
big Q over N. Assume
there's N identical firms.
And what that means
is that S0 equals
N minus 1 times little q.
The supply of everyone
else is the number of firms
in the market--
that's an N, big N--
number of firms in
the market minus 1,
because that's your
firm, minus little q,
because you're all identical.
Then we can rewrite this-- you
can do the math at home-- we
can rewrite this equation
as-- under these conditions,
we can rewrite this as
the elasticity of demand
facing firm i is equal
to the number of firms
times the market
elasticity minus N
minus 1 times the market
supply elasticity.
Nu is the market
eta is the market
demand elasticity.
eta i is the firm
So the firm demand
elasticity is equal to N--
I keep mixing my little
n's and my big N's.
It's all the same thing.
N times e-- so firm
demand elasticity
is equal to number of
firms times market demand
elasticity minus number of
firms minus 1 times the market
supply elasticity.
We know this is positive.
Supply curves slope up.
We know this is negative.
So we know it's a
negative number.
What's good about
this formula is
it gives us examples showing how
much bigger firm elasticity can
be than the market elasticity.
So for example, suppose,
as a simple example,
suppose N equals
100 suppose it's
100 people selling Eiffel
towers on their blankets
around the Eiffel Tower.
And suppose that the market
elasticity is minus 1--
that is, it's an
elastically demanded good.
It's not super
elastically demanded.
Basically, we call that an
elastically demanded good,
minus 1.
So it's sort of a 45-degree line
demand curve, a 45-degree line
demand curve sloping down.
And let's also imagine that
the elasticity of supply is 1.
That's a 45-degree line,
upward-sloping supply curve.
These are pretty
standard assumptions.
It's what I drew in lecture
1, a 45-degree demand
curve, a 45-degree supply
curve, with 100 firms.
That gives you that the
firm specific elasticity
is minus 199.
That is virtually flat.
That is approximately
negative infinity,
as far as these things go.
So basically, even with
just a regular-looking,
downward-sloping
demand curve, if it's
100 firms of
independent marketing,
you get a virtually flat
firm specific demand curve.
So it's not crazy that firms
in a really competitive market
would face essentially
perfectly elastic demand.
And that's the key
thing that's going on
in a perfectly
competitive market,
is firms themselves-- not
the market demand, the market
demand can be sensible-- but
firms themselves face virtually
perfectly elastic demand.
If you're all selling
little Eiffel towers next
to each other, then if you
try to raise your price by one
euro, you're gone.
No one buys from you.
If you lower it by one euro,
everyone buys from you.
That sort of makes sense.
Questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What
was the difference
between big Q and little q?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Little q is the
firm and big Q is the market--
very important to remember.
Always remember.
That's a middle of
the night thing.
When I wake you up in
the middle of the night,
you have to know that one.
Little q is the firm.
Big Q is the market.
Now, I'm not
guaranteeing I always get
that right on the board.
But I am guaranteeing if I
get it wrong, one of you guys
will correct me.
So armed with this--
any other question about this?
Armed with this, we now turn
to how firms maximize profits,
short-run profit maximization.
This is what we've
been heading for.
With consumers, our
goal was to model how
they maximize their utility.
With firms, our goal is to
model how they maximize profit.
Now, what is the key
thing in the short run?
The fact is that
short run means we're
going to make-- we
talk about short run
being capital is
fixed, but there's
one other assumption we're going
to make about the short run.
We're going to assume
no firm entry or exit.
It's sort of a complement
of capital being fixed.
Firms are you're in.
You make your capital
investment and you're in.
You could stop producing,
but you still already made
your capital investment.
Or in other words,
in the short run,
capital is a sunk
cost in the short run.
You're in.
And once the market starts,
no one new is coming in.
So you sort of roll
in this market.
People have announced to begin.
They've set up their blankets.
No one else has come
to set up a blanket
and no one's rolling up
their blanket and going home.
So now, let's ask first
question-- what is profit?
Well, that seems sort of easy.
Profit, as I wrote down earlier,
is just revenue minus costs.
And if you're taking one of
those goddamn boring counting
courses in course 15,
that's where you'd stop.
But you're not.
You're take an interesting
course 14 course instead,
where we tell you
that while this
may be the correct definition
of accounting profits,
accountants simply say,
you add up the revenues
you make minus the costs you
incur, and that's the profit.
But economists say,
wait a second--
that's not right,
because we also
have to account for opportunity
costs, as well as cash costs.
Let's do a simple example.
Let's say you're going
to start a website design
firm when you graduate.
And all the firm's
going to be is
you, some slave
programmer you're
going to hire for
$40,000, and the computer
they're going to use.
And moreover, let's
say you already
have a computer sitting around.
That's your computer.
It's in pretty good shape.
So you could just have the
slave work on that computer.
And you can just
basically say, look,
I'll pay this guy $40,000.
I'll think up all the
ideas and supervise them.
And then that's the way
the firm's going to work.
Let's say you do that, and
at the end of the first year,
you have sales of $60,000.
Then your accounting
profits are the $60,000
that you earned minus the
$40,000 you paid your employee.
So you've made a $20,000
accounting profit.
Why does that make no sense.
In fact, why are
economic profits,
the true profits from this
enterprise once you account
for opportunity cost negative.
What do the accountants
miss that economists get?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
something better.
JONATHAN GRUBER: The
opportunity cost of your time.
You just spent a
year doing this.
You could have been off
making a zillion dollars,
like you guys all will.
So we missed the opportunity
cost of your time.
Let's say you could have
graduated and gotten
a job at $80,000 a year.
Well then, actually,
the cost of the year
is not just the $40,000
you paid the programmer.
It's the $80,000 that
you forgoed by working
that year on your company.
What else?
What's the other
opportunity cost?
Much smaller, but
still relevant.
What could you've done
with the computer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
you could have done what?
AUDIENCE: You
could have sold it.
JONATHAN GRUBER: You could
have sold the computer, right.
Now, used computers
aren't worth that much,
but let's say you could
have gotten a grand for it.
Well, that's an
opportunity cost.
If you would just gone
on and used your--
now, you might get
all the utility
from the computer, whatever.
Let's put that aside.
But you just gave
it to this guy.
You never touched it,
literally got rid of it.
It was like you didn't have
the computer that year.
Then you could have sold it.
Let's say you could have
sold it for another $1,000.
So now, you've paid him $40,000.
You've given up $80,000
of earnings and $1,000
on the computer, so your true
costs are actually $121,000.
So actually, you
haven't made $20,000.
You've lost $61,000.
And that's why we don't care
about accounting profits.
We care about economic
profits, the difference
being economic profits account
for opportunity costs--
very important to remember.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The profits,
economic profits
will be higher than
financial profit or typically
[INAUDIBLE]?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
It all depends on--
it depends on there's
no way to assign it.
yeah.
AUDIENCE: You've been
talking about sunk costs
and opportunity costs.
Is it like [INAUDIBLE]
economics to consider time
to be a sunk cost,
like if you spend
a lot of time on something?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, no, it's not.
I mean, in some sense, a sunk--
basically, sunk costs is sort
of an irreversible fixed cost.
If you spend time on
it, yeah, in that sense,
from today's
perspective, it's sunk.
But the point is, the
more important concept
is that time is money, that
if you spent your time running
this business, that's
time you could've
spent doing something else.
Now, one thing we'll
come to in a couple
lectures, you might
say, well, hey,
I would've taken the year
off and screwed around.
So in fact, there
was no $80,000 cost.
What if instead of
running this company,
the only thing I want to do
in my life is run the company.
My second choice is watching TV.
So then there's no
opportunity cost.
That's wrong.
And we'll teach you
why in a few lectures.
I don't want you
to tell me why now.
I want you to think about
why, even if you would have
spent the year watching TV.
No, I don't.
I said, no.
Put your hand down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: I knew
you're going to try.
I love, I love that
willingness in this class
to answer questions.
This one I want you
to just think about,
because we're going to come
back to this in a few lectures.
Now, let's go on and talk
about maximizing profits.
Maximizing profits-- now that
we defined what profits are,
how do you maximize them?
We know how to
maximize a function.
If pi equals R minus C,
then the maximum d pi dq--
you can't control the price.
All you can control is
how much you produce.
Your only control
variable is q, little q.
So d pi dq equals dR d
little q minus dC d little q.
Know what dC d little q is.
We defined that last time.
What's that?
What do we call that, the
change in costs with respect
to an increment in quantity?
AUDIENCE: Marginal cost.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Marginal cost.
So we know this is
the marginal cost,
but for a competitive firm,
what is marginal revenue?
So that's marginal
revenue, the amount you
work on the next unit you sell.
For a competitive firm, what
is their marginal revenue?
What is the amount?
AUDIENCE: Price.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Price,
which is given to them,
because they're a price taker.
Firms, they don't have to think
about a complicated concept
here.
This is all complicated,
with tons of math.
I hated that last
lecture, all the math.
This is hard.
This is easy.
It's price.
You're given-- if
you're a price taker,
you're given a
price by the market.
So marginal revenue for a
perfectly competitive firm
is just price.
So you maximize profits when
price equals marginal cost is
the profit maximizing point.
Profits are maximized when
price equals marginal cost.
That is, you want to
produce until what
you get from the next
unit equals what you
spend to make the next unit.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if you make--
what if you move it
to cost a bit less
and you sell it for
below the market.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Let's
go to an example.
So let's go to figure 7.2.
Here we have the cost function
that we derived last time.
C of q equals 10
plus 5q squared.
You remember that
from last time.
And then we have a
revenue function,
and I assume the
price per unit--
we have a revenue
function where I'm
going to assume the
price per unit is 30.
For our example, I'm going
to assume P equals 30.
I've just made that up.
Once again, that comes from God
in these perfectly competitive
firms.
They have no idea
where this comes from.
It's just a price.
We'll talk later
where it comes from,
but for now, it's
just a given thing.
Let's say it's 30.
So the firm's cost
function is of the form--
is graphed on the
left-hand side here.
The revenue function is
simply a straight line,
which is 30 times q.
So if they sell one,
revenue is 30, two,
revenue is 60, et cetera.
And the profits are
simply the difference.
So when we maximize, how
do we maximize profits?
Well we want to graph--
what we want to do
is graph the profit
for each additional unit sold.
So for example, when
you go from selling
no units to selling one unit,
at no units, your cost is what?
If you sell no units,
what's your cost?
Somebody raise their
hand and tell me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 10.
JONATHAN GRUBER: 10,
not 0, because you
have the fixed costs.
Those are paid no matter what.
Remember, those are
fixed in the short run.
We'll come back.
This is very important.
So if you zero, your costs are
10, your revenues are what?
0, so your profits
are negative 10.
If you produce one
unit, what's your cost?
15.
What's your revenues?
30.
So you make a profit of 15.
If you go from one unit,
now you're producing one.
You want to know, should
I produce the second unit?
What's the marginal
cost of the second unit?
Well, we know what marginal
cost is with this function.
Marginal cost, we just
differentiate this with respect
to q and we get 10q
is marginal cost.
So we know the marginal cost
of the second unit is what?
20.
What's the revenues
from the second unit?
Well, that's linear.
It's 30.
So you're still making--
you're making a profit of 10
on that unit.
Now, we go to the third unit.
So right, now after two units,
you are still making profit.
Now we go to the third unit.
It's hard, because
we're discretizing
a continuous example, but
let's go to the third unit.
The third unit, what's the cost?
What's the marginal cost?
30.
What's the marginal revenue?
So you're at the profit
maximizing point.
You have climbed the hill.
You have maximized your profits.
What's your total
profits at that point?
Well, your total profits is 3
times 30, which is 90, minus 10
plus 5 times 3 squared.
Minus 10 plus 45 is 55.
So your total profits are 45.
That's your maximum profits.
That's the most
you're going to earn.
Now, coming to the question
that was asked a minute ago,
or a related version--
wait a second, if I
sell one more unit,
I still have positive profits.
So my profits were 45
selling three units.
The next unit, I'm
still in the black.
Why not sell more?
Why not sell one more unit?
Why not sell that fourth unit?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
going to cost you more
than it's going to give you.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right.
Because we always make marginal
decisions in economics.
We always ask what's the
next step I should take.
And the next step
is a losing step,
because the fourth unit,
what's your marginal cost?
40.
What's your revenue?
30.
So the fourth unit has
a negative 10 profit,
so you don't want to make it.
So profit maximization is
a hill-climbing exercise.
I like to think of it, and
I describe in my videos,
I think of it as
it's like you're
climbing a hill blindfolded.
All you know is whether you're
stepping up or stepping down.
And you need to figure out
when you get to the peak.
If you step up, if your
next step is upward,
you must be short of the peak.
If your next step is downward,
you must have passed the peak.
It's just keep going till your
next step leads to a flat part.
Your next steps, right
in front of the other.
That's what profit
maximization is.
The key thing is you can--
the key thing
about the blindfold
is you don't need to
see the big picture.
All you need to know is, is my
next step increasing my profits
or decreasing my profits?
If it's increasing,
I'm doing it.
If it's decreasing,
I'm going backwards.
That's all you need to know,
is just think about putting one
foot in front of the other.
Does that next unit make
me money or lose me money?
So that is how we think
of profit maximization.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the next [INAUDIBLE]??
You just stop it or--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well, that
is the optimal production.
That's pinning down how
much you want to produce.
Remember I said at
the biggest lecture,
the problem with
producer theory is
we have some set of
relationships between how
much we produce and costs.
It doesn't tell you how
much you should produce.
This tells you how
much to produce.
You have now solved
the firm's problem.
This one extra-- this imposition
of the perfect competition
constraint has allowed us to
finally solve the problem.
We have now solved
it, and we've said
that the firm, given
this cost function
and given a price of 30, a firm
should produce three units.
Done.
Just like before, we said,
we had this many pizzas
and cookies.
Now we're pinning down q.
Once we pin down q,
we can, of course,
go back and pin down l
and k, because l and k are
a function of q.
But this is where
it's one step harder.
So this extra step
we have to take
is we have to impose
the market condition
to get to the little
q we want to produce.
And in this case, that's 3.
Questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you know
how in the beginning,
you said that in a perfectly
competitive market,
the producers are
price [INAUDIBLE]??
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm having
trouble understanding
why all of the guys who
are selling Eiffel towers
wouldn't get together
and [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's just make all of the
Eiffel towers more expensive.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Great.
Great point.
That's exactly-- we call that
a monopoly or an oligopoly,
depending how you want
to think about it.
They essentially
could monopolize.
And we're assuming that
doesn't happen here.
And I'll talk later
about why that's
way harder than you think.
So we're starting-- once
again, in economics,
we always start with
simplifying assumptions
to draw general lessons.
Then we'll make some
more, and then we'll
come back to the
more complicated,
real-world examples.
But it turns out
virtually everything
we learn here is
still going to hold.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if--
JONATHAN GRUBER: We
can go back to it.
So now let's ask, how
big is the firm's profit?
How do we measure the
size of the profit?
Profit, if we think
about profits per unit,
profits equals
revenue minus costs.
So profits per
unit, profits per q,
equals revenues per
q minus costs per q.
What is this term, cost
divided by quantity?
What do we call that?
Average costs.
And how much do
you get per unit?
You just get the price.
So dR dq and R over
q are the same.
In a competitive
market, marginal price
and average price are the same.
It's the price.
So this just says
profits are equal--
profits for q are equal to
price minus average cost.
So your per-unit profits is
And we can see
that in figure 7.3.
Figure 7.3 shows our cost curves
for this 10 plus 5q squared
function we derived before.
And you can see we have
an average total cost
curve, which first declines
and then increases.
We have a marginal cost curve.
And then we have an average
cost curve, average total cost
curve.
And then we have average
variable and average fixed.
Now, we already announced
that the optimal production
level was three, where
price hit marginal cost.
What's our profit at three?
Our profit is the difference
between that price
and the average
cost of three units
over all the units we produce.
So the profit is actually 30.
So there's a discreteness
problem here.
I have to work this out.
The problem, I said 45 before--
it's 45 mathematically.
It's 30 in this because
of the continuity
problem of the sort
of discreteness
between two and three.
So the bottom line is,
in a continuous example,
this would be the same.
And the bottom
line is the profit,
is the difference between the
price and the average cost
times the number of units sold.
That's going to be the
bottom line profit.
Average cost here
is 10 over 3 is 3.
Let's see, let's make sure
we've got the math right here.
Average cost is 10
plus 5q squared.
So average cost is
10 over q plus 5q.
q is 3, so it's 3.33
plus 15, which is 18.33.
Yeah, no, my math
was right with 45.
This graph is wrong.
So our average cost is 18.33.
What's the revenue
at that point?
It's 30.
30 minus 18.33 times 3 is 45.
So it is 45.
Is that right?
30 minus 18, 12 point--
no, that's wrong.
No, 30, no, I got that wrong.
You're right.
It's 35.
So it all comes
from the discrete--
it's all about the problem
of a very discrete function
versus a continuous function.
The bottom line is this--
did I get right?
Yeah, 11.67 times 3 is 35.
So the bottom line is, we got
45 from a hill-climbing exercise
and 35 from this
graph is basically
a discreteness problem,
that in some sense,
in this continuous function,
they give you the same thing.
The bottom line is
the profit is equal
to-- we'll be clear on this
in the problem sets and exams,
what we're looking for.
The bottom line is the
profit is the difference.
The profit per unit
is the difference
between the average
costs, and the price
that you get for that unit.
Now, with that in
mind, let me ask you
the following question--
what if I imposed a
tax of $1 per unit?
What if I imposed a
tax of $10 per unit?
A $10 per unit tax, what would
that do to the cost curve?
Somebody, without looking
at the handout and cheating,
somebody tell me what's
the new cost curve
if I impose a $10 per unit tax?
What's the new cost curve?
What was the old cost curve?
The old cost curve was
10 plus 5q squared.
What's the new cost curve?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
That's the answer
that almost everyone always
gives the first time,
but it's not right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: 10 plus
5q squared plus 10q,
because I said per
unit I charge $10.
If I'd said a fixed tax of
$10, you would've been right.
It would've been
20 plus 5q squared,
but it's not, because it's
a per unit tax of $10.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: We'll
see that in a second.
It's just an easy
way to explain it.
So that's the new--
with a tax of $10 per
unit, the new cost function
is 10 plus 5q squared plus 10q.
Oh, good, we didn't
show that in 7.4.
So what does that do?
Well, we can go to
Figure 7.4 and see that.
Here, the marginal cost
and the average cost
have both risen by 10.
The old marginal cost was 10q.
Now, it's 10q plus 10.
So marginal cost
is now 10q plus 10.
Average cost used to
be 10 over q plus 5q.
Now it's 10 over
q plus 5q plus 10.
So the bottom line is both
marginal and average cost
have shifted up by 10.
What does that mean?
Well, first of all, it
changes optimal production.
If marginal cost is 10q plus
10, and our optimization
is set price equals
the marginal cost,
now we're setting 30
equals 10q plus 10.
30 equals 10q plus 10, which
says the optimal q drops to 2.
Subtract 10 from 30, divide
by 10, you get the optimal q.
Now that falls to 2, so now, you
only want to produce two units,
because the marginal
cost is higher
but the price is the same.
You're going to produce less.
So now, you're only going
to produce two units.
And you could see
that in the graph,
that your marginal cost hits
the price now at two units,
rather than hitting
it at three units.
You see that in Figure 7.4.
Your average cost
is also higher,
so you're going to make
less profits per unit.
So you're producing
fewer units and making
less profit per unit.
So the entire
rectangle is shrunk.
The rectangle has shrunk.
Yes, the entire
rectangle shrunk.
It shrunk because you're
selling fewer units.
And it shrunk because
you're getting
less surplus per-- you're
getting less profit per unit.
Remember, profit
per unit is price
minus average cost over quantity
or price minus average cost.
Since average cost
is higher, you're
getting less profit per unit.
You're selling fewer units
at less profit per unit.
So that tax has significantly
lowered your profit.
Questions about that?
Doesn't have to be a tax.
If I'd said suddenly,
whatever you're producing,
there was a change in
what it costs to produce,
any change in what
something costs
to produce in the
production function
can ultimately affect how
much you sell and you profit.
So one excise you can
show yourself at home,
imagine that I had said
there was a fixed tax of 10.
Actually, let me ask you this
question-- imagine I had said
there was a fixed tax of 10.
How would that have
affected your profit?
How would that affect the
amount you sell and your profit?
It's a fixed tax of
10, not 10 per unit.
How would that affect
how many units you'd sell
and what your profit is?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Both [INAUDIBLE]
would have less profit.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
You'd sell-- why would
you sell the same amount?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
affect your MC.
JONATHAN GRUBER: It wouldn't
affect your marginal cost.
Remember, profit
maximization is where
marginal cost equals price.
If I have a fixed tax, that's
an effective marginal cost,
but it does lower your
profits, because you've still
got to pay that extra tax.
So here, your profits
get doubly hit.
You sell less, and you
make less per unit.
With a flat tax, you would
sell the same amount,
but you'd make less per unit.
That's an important distinction.
I think I'll add
that for next year.
Now, one other important point--
the firm has one other
decision to make here
that we haven't covered
yet, which is that it has
to decide whether to shut down.
Now, remember I said
there's no entry and exit.
That means you can't literally
leave and go somewhere else,
but you can just walk away.
You can just literally say,
look, I'm not in this market
anymore.
I'm not going to go set
up shop somewhere else,
but I'm not in this
market anymore.
So the question is,
when would you do so?
So I'm going to get to it.
Hold on.
Is it a question or answer?
If it's an answer,
I don't want it yet.
If it's a question,
I'll take it.
So basically, suppose the price
in this market fell to $10.
Should you continue to
participate in the market?
Well, if the price
falls to $10, what
is the optimal
level of production?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Zero.
So does that mean
you should walk away?
No.
What are your profits?
If you sell zero,
what are your profits?
Negative 10.
If you shut down and walk
away, what are your profits?
Negative 15.
What's profits?
Profits is revenues minus costs.
Costs at zero--
I'm sorry, you
don't produce zero.
That's bad.
You produce one unit.
I got the answer wrong.
If price equals
marginal cost-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] with
the tax imposed, or are we--
JONATHAN GRUBER:
No, without the tax.
I'm sorry.
That's what I confused.
We're back to without the tax.
The price in the
market drops to $10,
so you produce one
unit, not zero.
I shouldn't listen to you.
I should look at my notes.
One unit, not zero.
You produce one unit.
At that point, what are your
revenues producing one unit?
You get 30.
Yeah, this example is messed up.
I'm going to have to
come back to this.
We made this-- this
example is wrong.
I'm going to have to
come back to this one.
So the key point with the
shutdown is basically,
you only want to shut
down if you're actually
going to lose more money
by staying in the market
than you get by
exiting the market.
So let me stop there.
I'll come back and fix this.
I made an error on this.
I'll come back to fix it at the
beginning of the next lecture.
And then we'll talk about
finishing up short-run profit
maximization.
So let's pause
there and come back.